vitesse que vous avez des regrets par
rapport à à vos enfants ou pas du tout
il a chéri alors moi j'ai qu'un j'ai
qu'un fils et moi j'ai le sentiment de
ne pas avoir été assez présent vous êtes
très occupé
réveillé très tôt alors il ya la radio
ici avec moi tous les jours
est-ce que vous avez des regrets il lui
a un regret d'être tout seul de ne pas
avoir de deux frères ont deux soeurs
dont qui sied très bien faire à la
longue
et après quand je me suis occupé très
près de ses études il a trouvé que
j'étais beaucoup trop présente ce que ça
se termine et à coups de bouquins sur la
tête je reconnais quand j'en avais
ras-le-bol
donc non qu'après ils étaient contents
de prendre du champ et de prendre
internat j mersen dorin moi j'ai une
fille qui a 12 ans et je me reconnais
exactement dans ce qu'il dit c'est à
dire que parfois vous avez élevé pas
avec moi tout le temps voit souvent mais
vous avez l'impression de ne pas être
assez présent et parfois donc vous
surcompensé vous appeler comme les comme
disait sa fille julie vous avez trop on
a fait 3 passes a fait trop donc c'était
très dur de trouver le juste équilibre
gens me motive c'est le regret qu'ils
sont générationnel j'avais des regrets
parce que vous avez des enfants des deux
journées 2 voilà et dont j'ai été séparé
des mamans très tôt de ma faute parce
que c'est moi qui écris moi qui ai
décidé de partir parce que j'avais pas
envie d'être volage contre affaires
sociales et j'ai préféré qu'on se quitte
ce sens conneries sans faire de
conneries
voilà mes gardes du corps des lieux mais
avec mes enfants mangent c'est vrai que
mais c'est une question de génération
j'ai beaucoup de mal à leur dire je
t'aime
voilà comme j'ai eu du mal à dire à mon
père je t'aime alors que je savais qu'il
allait partir et ça c'est le plus grand
regret de ma vie je pense est alors que
j allais pour ça et devant lui vous avez
été voir à l'hôpital
exactement quelles quantités quand je
suis arrivé il était conscient il savait
très bien et était médecin et savait
très bien mais plus pour très longtemps
je savais que c'était la fin et je
m'étais dit j'ai pas bien et express
expressément pour ça et même devant lui
j'ai parlé de chez lui dire mais je sais
qu'il le savait mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas vous qui savez il m'avait pas
dit non plus jamais jamais dit je t'aime
non plus mais je suis je pas faire la
même erreur je vais lui dire moi et du
coup je me rattrape sur mes enfants où
je leur dis beaucoup
c'est un super mec
[Applaudissements]